foreign
welcome to this interesting video on
blockchain in-depth tutorial blockchain
is a groundbreaking technology that
enables anyone to track transactions on
a distributed digital Ledger without a
central Authority
so this video will explore various
important aspects of blockchain and the
related Concepts in depth
but before diving deep into its concept
we will first explore the basics
starting with what blockchain is
features of blockchain like public
distributed Ledger encryption proof of
work mining smart contracts and its use
cases that will make your base even more
stronger
then we will dive down deeper into its
internal Concepts and learn about the
candidate blog Byzantine call tolerance
the addition of two blocks at the same
time
Forks like soft fork and at hard Forks
areas where blockchain is used what is
the future of blockchain and then we
will have a peek at blockchain jobs
available
following these we will understand why
we need blockchain and Its Real World
applications in healthcare government
blockchain and kyc trade Finance
mortgage industry loan Management
blockchain in Estonia energy markets
block media
travel supply chain and network security
like Korea Telecom
then we will see how to become a
blockchain developer the salary offered
to them and companies hiring blockchain
developers to boost your confidence
by the end of this video I can assure
you that all your blockchain related
Concepts will have been cleared
for this training with me I have
experienced specialist Sam and Rahul
together we'll walk you through the
different crucial blockchain Keynotes
and Concepts
so let's start with an exciting video on
blockchain in-depth tutorial but before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets Banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends Jack Ted
Sam and Phil meet up for dinner after
they're done Jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when Phil sends his share to Jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then Ted
and Sam send their respective shares to
Jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transaction cites
some issues at the bank that's when Jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems alums the concept of
cryptocurrency came into existence
cryptocurrencies are a form of digital
or virtual currency that run on a
technology known as blockchain thanks to
blockchain cryptocurrencies are immune
to counterfeiting don't require a
central Authority and are protected by
strong and complex encryption algorithms
and in a market of more than thousands
of cryptocurrencies like Litecoin
ethereum Z cash and so on one reign
supreme Bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have Phil Ted and
Sam Send Jack two Bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume Phil Ted and Sam
have three Bitcoins in reserve while
Jack has five first Phil sends two
Bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block This Record also
holds the number of Bitcoins each of the
friends own so after Phil's transaction
Jack has seven Bitcoins while Phil has
won following this Sam and Ted's send
two Bitcoins to jack a new block is
created for each of these transactions
these blocks hold the transaction
details as well as how many Bitcoins Sam
Ted and Jack have in reserve these
blocks are linked to each other as each
of them takes reference from the
previous one for the number of Bitcoins
each brand owns this chain of Records or
blocks is called a ledger and this
Ledger is shared among all the friends
which acts as a public distributed
Ledger this forms the basis of
blockchain so what happens when Phil has
only one Bitcoin left and he tries to
send two more Bitcoins to Jack the
transaction will not go through this is
because all his friends have copies of
The Ledger and it's clear that Phil has
only one Bitcoin left his friends will
flag this transaction as invalid a
hacker will not be able to alter the
data in the blockchain because each user
has a copy of The Ledger the data within
the blocks are encrypted by complex
algorithms all of this is made possible
with the help of blockchain Technology
blockchain can be described as a
collection of Records linked with each
other strongly resistant to alteration
and protected using cryptography now
let's have a closer look at the Bitcoin
transaction between Jack and Phil and
find out how it works every user in the
Bitcoin network has two keys a public
key and a private key the public key is
an address that everyone in the network
knows of like an email address of a user
the private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first bill passes the
number of Bitcoins he wants to send to
Jack along with his and Jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are in
encrypted using encryption algorithms
and using Phil's unique private key this
is done to digitally sign the
transaction and to indicate that the
transactions came from fill this output
is now transmitted across the world
using Jack's public key with this the
message or transaction can be decrypted
only by Jack's private key which only
Jack has knowledge of different
cryptocurrencies use different hashing
algorithms while Bitcoin uses the
sha-256 algorithm ethereum which is also
a famous cryptocurrency uses one known
as ethash this transaction and several
other similar ones are taking place all
around the world these transactions are
validated and then added block by block
the people who validate these blocks are
called miners for a block to be
validated and added to a blockchain
miners need to solve a complex
mathematical problem The Miner who
solves this first adds the block to the
blockchain and is rewarded with 12.5
Bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining with this Phil and Jack's wallets
are updated just like every person in
the network who has completed a
transaction now that you know about
blockchain and its important Concepts
time for a small quiz what is the
concept of blockchain that ensures data
cannot be altered by any of the users
within the network a public distributed
Ledger B proof of work C proof of stake
D hash encryption let us know what you
think is the right answer in the
comments below three lucky winners will
get Amazon gift vouchers details are
mentioned in the description below let's
have a look at how Walmart uses
blockchain to provide its customers with
better service Walmart was facing
problems in delivering quality products
to its customers they were facing a high
return rate and large amounts of refunds
due to their products bad quality they
were unable to determine the point of
failure in the supply chain which
started from Farm to storage to
transportation to processing all the way
to the customer then Walmart adopted
blockchain technology with blockchain
the quality of the goods at each step
was permanently inscribed within a block
for example when a customer Flags a
product as damaged it can be correctly
identified where the product got damaged
in the entire supply chain thus helping
Walmart to identify by the problem areas
and fixing them and this is just one of
several ways blockchain is used in real
life applications can you think of any
others let us know in the comments down
below that's all for now hello everyone
and welcome to this session of
blockchain tutorial part one my name is
saurabh and I'm part of the simply learn
team so let's get started and understand
what's in it for us today so let's take
a hypothesis in our city not so far away
somebody was up to something bad so
there's a hacker who hates the bank who
wants to steal the money of all the
people lying in the bank now here's why
I hate them even more what are the
nuances and the problem areas of the
banking system the banking system has
higher transactional and international
transfer costs a lot of documentation is
required for setting up of an account
for opening an account and onboarding a
customer and the banking system is not
always accessible it's not 24x7 it's
closed on banking holidays and it has
other limitations also like transfer
limits in a day and you know you can't
transfer x amount within a stipulated
time now banks in such an ecosystem acts
as a center point of failure it is a
centralized based system which is prone
to failure from a centralized point of
view so if the bank fails all the
transactions will come to an halt which
are dependent on the bank now let's see
what happens if the hacker is able to
get into the banking system and hacks
the bank all the investors or the people
associated with the bank the information
associated with them will get corrupted
will get jeopardized and it can lead to
huge losses to the bank and to the
individuals and all this can happen with
a click of a button it's as simple as
that so once a hacker has access to the
system he can manipulate the system
compromise the information share it with
the parties which are not supposed to
have that information and lot can go
wrong though the hackers can be caught
right it is possible through cyber
security and various means but once the
information is compromised it is very
difficult to roll that back and that's
why we need more secure systems and
systems which are not dependent on a
centralized Authority which work in a
more decentralized fashion whereby
making it hack proof plus lowering the
transaction cost also now this incident
of course will catch the bank manager's
attention now he will go to his advisors
and want to make sure this does not
happen again so the technology com
people the advisors will make sure that
this does not happen but what is the
remedy so the remedy is setting up a
blockchain now of course the manager
who's looking into the banking functions
might not be aware of the technology and
what benefits blockchain bring onto the
table in order to prevent such an
incident so that's what we are here for
we will learn before we go and
understand what can blockchain actually
achieve for us so we will understand
today what is blockchain the Bitcoin
story the features of blockchain like
public distributed Ledger the hashing
encryption the proof of work consensus
algorithm and the concept of Mining and
then we will cover up a use case where
how blockchain can be used for banking
operations now what is blockchain
blockchain is a list of Records called
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order and the entire
information is persisted using
cryptography it is secured using
cryptography so cryptography ensures
that the privacy of the user is
maintained and data cannot be altered
information on a blockchain network is
not controlled by a centralized
Authority for unlike modern financial
institutions nobody controls the data
within a blockchain the data is
maintained by the participants of the
network and they are the Democratic
Authority in order to approve any
transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network access to anyone on
the network so a typical blockchain
network is a public blockchain so as
long as you have access to the network
you have access to the data within the
blockchain if you are a participant on
the blockchain network you will have the
same copy of The Ledger which all other
participants have so therefore everyone
every participant on the network has the
same copy of the data so everyone in the
network has a copy of the blockchain
data which is used for ensuring that
data remains untempered so even if one
node or data on one particular
participant computer gets corrupted the
other participants will come to know
immediately that this particular
instance or node has gone corrupted and
they will Rectify it as soon as possible
so basically the question is is this the
same technology that Bitcoin works on
and the answer is yes Bitcoin could not
have been possible without blockchain so
we will understand how Bitcoin adopted
blockchain in order to reach to its
Journey today so Bitcoin was introduced
in 2009 by someone or a group of people
known as Satoshi nakomoto it aimed to
solve the problem faced by Fiat
currencies with the help of blockchain
Technology now as of today in 2018 there
are more than 1600 cryptocurrencies that
follow the concepts of Bitcoin and
blockchain for example the other popular
cryptocurrencies are like ethereum
Litecoin Dash Ripple and many more now
let me explain how a Bitcoin transaction
works the sender transmits the
transaction details worldwide basically
whenever a sender has to do a
transaction he has to send Bitcoins to a
receiver he will submit the transaction
on the public blockchain network of
Bitcoin and transmit it now verification
to authenticate users it is done by the
miners around the world so basically
there are specific participants in the
Bitcoin Network which are called as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender and the
receiver and also validate whether the
sender has the right amount of balance
for the Bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver and ensuring that
the sanity of the underlying blockchain
Network to the Bitcoin remains correct
and not get corrupted so once the miner
has authenticated the transaction
verified all the parameters the
transaction is added to a block and then
that block is made part of the main
blockchain once the block is added to
the blockchain the money the
transactions which were associated in
the block then gets executed money is
deducted from the sender's wallet and is
added to the receiver wallet thereby
once the transaction is completed the
block is added and The Ledger across all
the nodes are updated each and every
participant Ledger copy is updated with
that particular block which has been
added in the blockchain so therefore all
the participants have the same copy of
the information now so what makes
blockchain special now these are the the
special four features of blockchain
which we're going to talk about in
detail it is a public distributed Ledger
it works using a hashing encryption each
and every block has a hash value which
is the digital signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network using
proof of work consensus algorithm and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources of the miners who are there to
validate the transaction and the miners
in lieu of putting your investing in the
resources and validating the
transactions get rewards in terms of
Bitcoin and that process is called
mining now public distributed ledger so
let's imagine four friends sharing a
particular document amongst each other
correct now if there was only a single
copy of that document and one of them
altered the data it may go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them had a copy of the
data so therefore 4 if each and every
participant has the same copy of the
data even if one of them change the data
the others would find that the data does
not match with their own blockchain
Works in a similar fashion the data
within a blockchain is accessible to
everyone so with this as long as you are
part of the network you could access the
entire history of transactions that have
taken place since the blockchain was
created since Inception and the first
block in any blockchain is called the
Genesis block so from the Genesis block
to the current block you will have the
access to the entire chain any additions
to blockchain have to be approved by the
participant users in the blockchain
network so a majority of the members
within the network have to approve of
any additions to the blockchain this is
the public part of The Ledger and this
is important because any additions made
to the blockchain are permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which can cannot be
altered once registered they cannot be
modified and are available for audit and
verification 24x7 so this means that
each and every detail is recorded and
any alterations can be detected by
verifying it against everyone's personal
version of the blockchain so if
someone's tried to modify a data on a
block on a particular node then the
other ledgers which are having the same
information will come to know that
someone has modified data on a one
particular node and they will try to
rectify it and the fourth property no
Central Authority is controlling the
working of this blockchain network it is
a decentralized network so this is where
being decentralized helps everyone has a
copy of the blockchain which means there
is no central point of failure there is
a single source of truth even if things
go wrong the data can be recovered if
one node goes wrong the data can be
recovered from other nodes but what
about security how is privacy maintained
if everything is so public and here
hashing encryptions comes into picture
it takes care of that so now we will
talk about the second feature which is
hashing encryption but to understand
hashing encryption we need to understand
the contents what are the contents of a
block so a block in a blockchain is like
a container that holds aggregated
transactions it contains certain set of
transactions so we will see what all
things construct a particular block so a
block has two parts it has a header and
it has the second part is the
transaction details it is the set of
transactions which are aggregated in
this block now the header has following
set of attributes it has the block
version number it has the hash of the
previous block to which it is linked the
current timestamp the timestamp at which
the block was verified the nons we will
see what is the attribute what is the
meaning of nons and Target value now the
transaction details are nothing but the
example which we talked about earlier it
is the transaction which the sender and
receiver are sharing the sender is
trying to send certain amount of Bitcoin
from his account to the receiver's
account now it is represented in the
form of a 256 bit hash value in the
header called as Merkel root or the hash
root so basically the Merkel root is the
hash of all the transactions structured
in a Merkel tree called binary tree it's
a kind of a binary tree and the hash
value of the root node of the Merkel
tree is called the Merkel root hash so
the transaction details of a block are
contained in the header in a hex value
known as Merkel root the Merkel root can
be calculated in this way so basically
the list of transaction each transaction
is passed through a hashing algorithm
then all the hashes of the transactions
are paired and then again passed through
another hashing algorithm until only one
value remains and which will be the root
now let me tell you how a hash function
Works blockchain utilizes a hash
function to perform cryptography data
from a data set of random size is sent
as input to a hashing function to get an
encrypted value of fixed size and that
is the feature of any hashing function
so some unique properties of hashing
function are these are deterministic the
same input will always produce the same
hash output small changes in the data
can drastically change the output
basically any small change to the input
produces an output that's drastically
different from its previous obtained
outputs it can be computed easily the
output values can be obtained without a
whole lot of calculation and hashing
functions are one-way functions
basically you won't be able to determine
the input based on the output value so
you can't do the reverse calculation now
let's go back to our block we were
talking about earlier so as we were
discussing what are the features in the
header the the previous hash is the
resultant hash of the previous Block in
the blockchain and this is the way two
blocks are linked together now
transaction details these are used to
provide details about the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them and this is a list
of transactions and they are structured
in a Merkel tree and the hash of the
Merkel root is put in the header non is
a value that is varied to create a
unique hash address of the block which
should be less than the target hash
value so this is the structure of the
header it has a block version number
basically the sequence number of the
block it has the hash of the previous
block the timestamp when the blog post
mined and verified the nonce value the
header is then this entire header is
then passed through a hashing algorithm
in the case of a Bitcoin Network it is
sha256 and a hash value is generated and
now this hash value becomes the hash
value of the block now this value is a
256 bit value that is used to uniquely
identify the particular block so sha-256
ensures that alterations to data can be
easily detected so for example consider
these two blocks in the blockchain they
have a similar structure and definitely
different hash values now if someone
Alters the transaction details in the
first block the corresponding hash value
of the block would change too now the
values of hash value of the first block
and the previous hash value of the other
block will not match basically the block
subsequent to the Hacked block will get
dealing now this will raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place the users
will then be able to flag the block so
the alteration can be easily identified
and rectified immediately to ensure
security blockchain also include digital
signatures these ensure that the mess
message come from the right identity
right person and that the message is not
tampered with users are provided their
own private and public key so whenever a
user onboard a public blockchain he is
provided a pair of public and private
key now private key is used by the user
to control his her own account this is
kept as a secret by the user so
basically it says like his own password
and public key public key is used to
identify the user on the network this is
shared by the user along with the
transaction on the network for others to
verify so these are the steps involved
in creating and authenticating a digital
signature so at the center side the
message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm in in this
case of Bitcoin it is SSH 256 and the
hash is generated plus the private key
is used to generate a digital signature
now this output is passed through a
signature algorithm along with the
user's private key to create a digital
signature now during the transmission
the user's message their digital
fingerprint which was generated in the
previous step plus the public key are
transmitted across the network so these
three things are published on the
network for the validators for the
miners to use and verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receiver's end first the message is
passed through a hashing algorithm now
at the same time the sender's public key
and his or her digital signature are
passed through a verification algorithm
now both the functions will generate a
hash if both the hashes are compared and
if they match then the transaction and
the identity of the sender is approved
otherwise it is rejected so basically
this is the process by comparing the
hash values to authenticate the identity
of the sender now what about the people
who verify these transactions and how do
they actually do it so remember that one
field in the block header called norms
that becomes very important in order to
verify the transaction so now we will
talk about the third feature which is
the proof of work consensus algorithm so
proof of work involves people around the
world the participants in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one to add a block to the blockchain and
in lieu of this they will be rewarded
there are competing miners around the
world they are trying to solve a
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so this is the reward so
thereby they invest in the computing
power they invest in the resources in
order to mine and validate a transaction
to get that reward now what is the
mathematical puzzle so basically they
need to find a hash value that satisfies
certain predefined conditions now in
order to find the hash value they will
use Norms so this target hash value is
decided months in advance for everyone
lock the miners keep variating the nonce
value to find out an output that falls
within the target requirement so they
keep on generating a hash value using
the nons and if it is less than the
target the hash value is accepted and if
it is greater then the hash values
rejected the miners effort is not
considered valid now a minor transmits
across the world that he has found a
nonce that satisfies the target
requirement as soon as you find it and
thanks to the hashing algorithm used
this claim can be easily verified by
others so basically the proof of work
algorithm it is very hard to generate
the nons and get the hash value but it
is very easy to verify the transaction
by the other miners so that's whole lot
of work what a miners payoff is so for
all his or her hard work they get paid
in the Bitcoins and this is the only way
the Bitcoin get added to the network
sometimes they get other forms of
remuneration as well and this is the
concept of mine training so the entire
process when the miner has done the
proof of work consensus they are
rewarded and this is called as mining so
mining is the process of adding a block
to the blockchain this Miner is the
first person who found a nonce value
that fell within the target requirement
right now for doing this the miner is
rewarded as of today on the Bitcoin
Network a minor is paid 12.5 Bitcoins
for adding a block onto the blockchain
but the reward a miner gets reduced by
half every four years so when the fourth
year will approach for the threshold the
Bitcoin reward will go down to 6.25
Bitcoins and miners also get the sum of
all the transaction fees for that
particular block so the 12.5 Bitcoin
reward is Justified as mining is a very
expensive process it has a heavy toll on
electricity computing power and other
resources on which the miner has tested
now we will take a look at the use cases
where blockchain is applicable in Banks
so we have been incorporating a program
where Banks can validate user identity
and as of now a user needs to do the
process over and over again in each Bank
he has to go and prove the identity in
each bank is there a way we can ease a
process with blockchain and the answer
is yes we can we will be using truffle
ethereum ganache and smart contracts all
of these blockchain technology ecosystem
to make it work and welcome to this demo
for how to build your kyc blockchain
application now I'm gonna show you all
the steps required to deploy your kyc
application what all components are to
be developed and how to go about
deploying and testing your application
so primarily this kyc application will
allow Banks to do a decentralized kyc of
the customers which come to their Banks
so in the demo we will see when a
customer walks into the initiating bank
will do the kyc for a customer enter its
details and verify it and if any
subsequent Bank wants to use the kyc
done by another bank he or she needs to
take the permission of the customer and
then you can use the same kyc for
verification so we will see how can we
do that so just to start off with we
have developed a kyc solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order to do the actions required for
doing a kyc of a particular entity by
the bank now once this contract is ready
we will be placing it in our sample
truffle package so this is my truffle
package and in this I have the contracts
folder in the contracts folder I have
kept my kyc DOT solve file
now in the command prompt I will
compile my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which I
have just started and in my ganache
client as you can see it is running on
Port 8545 and it has already given me 10
accounts pre-funded with 100 ether now I
had already mentioned that my truffle is
connected to localhost 8545 so now when
I'll do my truffle my grid command it
will connect to my ganache and deploy my
kyc contract so now I can go to Triple
control and for me it's very important
to see at which particular address my
solidity contract has been deployed I'll
copy it
and in my
UI code under root jscontract details.js
I will make the change of this address
where my contract has now been deployed
now after doing these steps my
application is ready to interact with my
solidity contract which is being
deployed on my local blockchain network
now as you can see when I deployed the
contract this is my primary account from
which the ethers were deducted in order
to deploy the contract now there are
certain steps in order to get the
application up and running so first we
need to sign up the banks
so suppose I say Bank 1 and the password
should be the first address of the bank
so basically we are associating One bank
with one account which we have on our
ethereum Network so we will sign up now
bank one is successfully registered so
how I now in order to login I can check
now bank one I have logged in now I need
to do add a kyc for a particular
customer
now after filling the basic details I
will create the customer and the
username I have kept is customer one
ideally this is the unique identity of
the customer it can be any social
security number or vidhar number or any
unique identity which is attached to the
customer or the email ID and can be used
as the unique identifier for the
customer now once customer profile is
successfully created we need to log in
as a customer to allow this bank to see
the kyc details now suppose if I say
customer one and search it it is saying
it is denied and take the permission
from customer to proceed so before the
bank can do the kyc complete the
customer need to approve it so I am
creating the credentials for the
customer
now customer can see his details
whatever were filled by bank one and he
can see that there is a request from
bank 1 to allow to view his kyc now
before we allow I will also create
another bank bank 2 and Associate it
with my another address
and try to log in with it
now bank 2 is also logged in now bank 2
has not done the original kyc right but
it is trying to look up and its access
is also denied so it needs to explicitly
take permission so the bank will take
explicit requests from the customer
so now the customer has requests from
bank 1 and bank 2 for the kyc it is up
to the customer whether he or she wants
to allow and deny the kyc request after
the permission has been granted then
only the banks can be able to view the
kyc so if I say Bank One allow and bank
to deny
now all the requests are done from the
queue so bank one was allowed and bank 2
was denied so if I again login with
Bank One
and the password is my first address
View kyc Customer one
so here it is the bank one is able to
see the details now if I log in as bank
2 and give password and try to see the
it is saying permission denied so let's
ask bank2 to again request
now Bank two is now again a quest thing
and now this time it allows
now bank 2 can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end are
happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods now the
primary details of the contract are in
the contract details.javascript where we
have to provide the address at which the
contract was deployed the ABI file the
API so you can get the Avi at here this
is the Avi and you can paste it here and
this is the binary data
which has to be
pasted over here so the binary data can
be fetched
from remix
this is the binary data for the contract
it has to be copied and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to interact in
a decentralized fashion to access the
kyc records of a particular customer now
we can modify
the details also
and we can add a new customer again so
this is a basic demo of how a typical
kyc application works in a banking
environment blockchain expert now not
quite yet there's a lot of more
information you need to learn we'll go
to that later now let's do a quick recap
so what have we learned today we learned
what is blockchain the Bitcoin story we
understood the public distributed Ledger
concept hash encryption the proof of
work consensus algorithm the concept of
Mining and the use case of know your
customer blockchain decentralized
application which is used in Banks and
the use case of blockchain in Banks
hello everyone and welcome to this
session of blockchain tutorial part two
my name is saurabh and I'm part of the
simply learn team so let's get started
today and let's see what's in store for
us so hey thanks for coming back to
explain how blockchain work so in our
last session just let's do a quick recap
what we have learned so let's let's look
down the memory lane and discover what
we had learned we learned about what
blockchain is so a blockchain is a list
of Records which stores data publicly in
a chronological order it applies
security using cryptography it is not
controlled by a centralized Authority
any information on a blockchain network
is accessible to anyone on the network
and as it is a distributed Ledger it's a
shared Ledger everyone has the copy of
the data so these are the primary
attributes of a blockchain also you
learned about Bitcoin and how it works
just to do a quick recap it was
introduced in 2009 by someone or a group
of pseudonymous people known as Satoshi
Nakamoto is aimed to solve the problems
faced by Fiat currencies with the help
of blockchain technology so the
objective was to introduce a new asset
class of cryptocurrencies which can be
used in day-to-day transactions now as
of in 2008 18 there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies that follow the concept
of Bitcoin and blockchain and are very
popular in our day-to-day lives now
let's talk about the features of
blockchain is the public distributed
Ledger it uses a hashing encryption to
encrypt all the information on the
blockchain it uses proof of work
consensus algorithm for a consensus
mechanism and it works with the concept
of mining in order to reward the miners
for keeping them and maintaining the
sanity of the network and finally about
how you can Implement blockchain in a
banking system so we talked about how to
implement a kyc based blockchain
decentralized app and how it allows you
to create a decentralized banking system
where a kyc done by a One bank can be
leveraged by another bank and the
customer does not have to go through
multiple kyc iterations with each and
every Bank whom he or she wants to
transact with now we will get a little
deeper into blockchain and today we will
talk about these topics we will talk
about what is a candidate block we will
talk about Byzantine fault tolerance
which was one of the earlier consensus
mechanisms then we will talk about the
problem of if we have to add two blocks
at the same time then how does
blockchain handles that then we will
talk about the concept of forking what
are soft folks what are hard folks and
other areas where blockchain is getting
used what is the future of blockchain
and what are the upcoming blockchain
jobs and the profiles which are upcoming
in the market and then in the end we
will do a quick demo on how to create a
smart contract and deploy it for a
particular use case now before a block
can be mined a miner has to make an very
important decision which transactions
would be added to his block so before
transactions are added to the blockchain
they are collected in a temporary
container called a memory pool the
miners select transactions from the
school and they put it in a temporary
block called candidate block so
basically the candidate block is a
temporary block which a miner hopes to
add to a blockchain it's a candidate to
be added to a blockchain so the
candidate block holds transactions that
the miners selects from the memory pool
The Miner then tries to be the first
person to find the nonce value that
satisfy the hash requirements now the
question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data by spreading wrong information
around would he or she be able to get
away with it and that's why we had
something known as Byzantine fault
ronderance so in order to maintain the
sanity of the network and to have the
correct consensus there was something
called as Byzantine fault tolerance
consensus algorithm to understand this
you need to know what the Byzantine
generals problem is so let's imagine a
Byzantine General and three other the
lieutenants need to take over this town
however they are at different places and
can't directly communicate with each
other so here we have the general and
his three lieutenants the general has to
ensure that all lieutenants follow the
same order he or she gives them to
attack or to retreat now this has to be
ensured even if one of the lieutenants
is a traitor so this is the Byzantine
General's problem that how does the
general communicates the correct
decision which he has taken to all his
lieutenants in his Network irrespective
if someone is a traitor in this case a
traitor could ruin the unity of the
group by sending different messages to
different lieutenants now here we can
see that General is giving all his
reference the command to attack the
traitor could ruin this by sending every
other Lieutenant the command to retreat
the opposite now in this situation the
traitor would make others believe that
the General asked them to retreat so as
we can see the lieutenant in brown is
the traitor and he could communicate to
other lieutenants the wrong information
and make them act on his behalf as a
traitor themselves now this would cause
the lieutenants to retreat and the
General's attack to fail so how do we
tackle this the only way an attack or a
retreat will be successful is by having
a majority supporting that particular
action to achieve this the lieutenant
keep a tally of the orders they receive
so in this scenario the general sends
the attack order to each of his
lieutenants the lieutenants in turn
collect the order they receive and pass
it on to the lieutenant near to them so
each Lieutenant will pass this order to
the nearest left in it the Tracer also
will do the same but ends The Retreat
order to the other left lens however
this will not be successful because each
Lieutenant now has a majority of of
attack and minority of retreat so this
shows that the majority of the
lieutenants would follow the General's
command and the attack will be
successful the scenario I mentioned
before is Byzantine fault tolerance now
the same station can be encountered in
blockchain as well the traitor would add
invalid transactions into the blockchain
the traitor would send the inconsistent
information to other nodes in a
blockchain this would affect the
reliability of blockchain the network
blockchain are able to achieve Byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see how it is effective it
is effective because the process of
adding a block to a blockchain is a work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process is very
hard very computive because it is
heavily reliant on value obtained from
the existing blockchain to have any
meaningful impact the hacker would have
to take a lot of time resources
producing sufficient proof of work
interesting imagine if you and I were
miners and we both add a block to the
blockchain at the same time how do we
handle such a situation so although this
does not happen very often there is a
way to decide whose block should be
added to the blockchain in an ideal
scenario you just need to be the first
one to find the hash value you need to
be the first Miner to generate that hash
value and win the block so adding two
blocks at the same time the hash value
of the block only needs to be within the
predetermined limit if the generated
hash value is less than the target then
the value is accepted and the block is
added to the blockchain but if it is
greater than the target then the value
is denied and the block is not added to
the blockchain but in this case if two
people have obtained a satisfactory hash
value at the same time so my minor 1 and
minor 2 we are able to find the hash
which was less than the target then what
will happen whether minus one block will
get added to the blockchain or minus 2
block will get added to the blockchain
Now 50 of the network has accepted minus
one block and suppose rest has accepted
minus two blocks so half of the network
continues to work considering minus one
block to be the right block and the
other half Network continues to work
considering -2 block to be the right
block however only one minus blockchain
can be allowed to remain we cannot have
two blockchains running it will defeat
the purpose now this is achieved by
selecting the substance to which miners
have first added a block so suppose
minor 3 adds a new block to miners 1
blockchain this block now added by minor
3 is verified by everyone in the network
it is then accepted as the dominant
blockchain and is used by everyone else
is in the network the other version of
the blockchain The Miner 2 is completely
discarded and the entire network now
accepts minor one's blockchain and we
have now a single blockchain existing
now this situation is also called an
accidental Fork so I heard about a
version of Bitcoin called Bitcoin cash
what's the difference between them there
are other kinds too like Bitcoin gold
and Bitcoin private these are all
outcomes of a fork so what is a fork a
fork is said to have taken place when a
blockchain diverges into two potential
Parts a fork happens when the users of a
network cannot come to an agreement with
regards to a Network's transaction
details and the new rules to validate
those transactions so there are two
types of forks which can exist either it
can be a soft work or it can be a hard
Fork a soft Fork occurs when a change in
the Soft C protocol makes new block
added to the blockchain following the
new rules but are Backward Compatible
but in order to have a soft work it
requires a majority of the users to
commit to that change to be successful
so a soft Fork could have multiple uses
it could be for tighter rules it could
be for cosmetic changes addition of new
functions but not affecting the
structure so consider the scenario where
the accepted block size is to be reduced
from 1 MB to 100 KB so first of all it
has to be approved by a majority of the
network now the old version will be
running on 1mb block size but once
approved the new version will start
working on a block size of 100 KB so
anything which is less than 100 KB will
be approved and will be added to the new
block so over time people following the
older version of the blockchain would be
forced to move to the new one since none
of the transactions would go through so
basically people using the old
blockchain they will be using the 1mb
block size their transactions will not
succeed and they will be forced to use
the 100 KB block now let's talk about
hard Fork a hard Fork involves a change
in the software protocol so radical that
it forces a new blockchain to be created
all together so basically in a hard Fork
there will be two versions there will be
one blockchain that hasn't upgraded and
there will be a blockchain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols both these blockchains will be
considered valid and legitimate the New
Path would follow new updated rules
while the other one keeps following the
old path so the old one will not be
discarded and will remain into existence
now Bitcoin performed a hard Fork on 1st
August 2017 which created bitcoin cash
so thereby both Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash
remain existent now Bitcoin cash was
different from regular Bitcoin because
us it increased the block size from 1 MB
to 8 MB so thereby it helped reducing
the transaction cost significantly
lesser than that of the original Bitcoin
Network now other than with Bitcoin
where else is blockchain used the other
areas are for preventing voter fraud
blockchain helps in ensuring that there
is only one vote per person ensuring
that the data is not being tampered with
or any false alterations are done it
helps creating an immutable ledger to
record the votes as tallied so once a
transaction or a vote is recorded it
cannot be modified it is also used in
quality assurance ensuring the products
are of highest quality being able to
identify problem areas easily so where
do you think blockchain is going to be
used in the future so blockchain is
seeing wide range of adoption amongst
organizations as of now only one percent
of all organ organizations have begun
using blockchain Technologies but this
percentage is expected to increase in
the next five years or so then there is
a need for blockchain regulations the
rules and regulations surrounding
blockchain are not very clear for
organizations to be comfortable using it
and move towards faster adoption also
there's a need for removing this
negative speculations surrounding
blockchain several Industries fear that
blockchain will disrupt their normal
functioning and believe that the
adoption of a blockchain system is
inward the effort and there is an
increase in job opportunities for
skilled Personnel so as the technology
is maturing there would be a huge
requirement for individuals who can
understand and implement the concepts of
blockchain so what options do people
have for jobs involving blockchain at
the moment there are many job
opportunities but the two most famous
ones are blocked in architect and
blockchain developer blockchain
developer is a profile which requires
designing implementing and supporting a
distributed blockchain Network analyze
user requirements Design Technology
around a certain business model to build
and launch a blockchain network
blockchain architect profile requires to
design and architect blockchain industry
Solutions creates blockchain networks
leveraging blockchain technology
platforms produce high quality code
based on Project requirements
conceptualize design and build
blockchain Frameworks and assets so
let's have a quick demo on how to deploy
a rating smart contract and have
decentralized application running on a
local blockchain network we will be
using truffle and solidity to build this
application so in order to build this
application we should have installed
truffle and ganache on our local system
so this is a ganache client which is
running on my Local Host it is running
on Port 8505 and network ID 57 778
whenever you run a ganache client it is
preceded with 10 accounts and 100 ether
balance now this is my movie rating app
and in this app I am going to deploy a
smart contract called rating dot Soul
which is gono capture the ratings for a
certain set of movies which I'll
pre-define and the users will be able to
set the ratings on a blockchain network
in a decentralized fashion and we will
be able to see that in every transaction
a block is getting generated in my
ganache client so in my movie rating app
under the rating folder I will run the
command trough compile and it will
compile my smart contract rating dot
Soul now the next command which I have
to run is trough migrate
now at this instance the trough migrate
command will deploy my smart contract on
my ganache client so if you see there
are four blocks which have been created
and
my contract was created in this
transaction and this is the address of
the contract at which my contract is
deployed so I can go back to my command
prompt and say trough console and check
the address of my contract so this is
0x695 which is this address now when I
deployed my smart contract I had given
the entry of deployment in a file called
deploycontract.js under rating
migrations and in that I had given this
entry I had given the path to my rating
solidity file and I had initialized my
smart contract with three movies Star
Wars Avatar and Inception and given some
predefined gas now once these steps are
done and I know the address at which my
contract is deployed I will copy that
and paste it
in the file of ethereumsetup.js which is
lying under my rating app UI Source
folder and I'll just change this address
now once this rating address is changed
I have to go back to my movie rating app
folder under app UI I have to give the
command npm start
now my application is up and running on
localhost 3000 and as you see I'm able
to do the voting and at each rating
level my block is going to increase
block 6 Inception block 7 and as and
when my rating is increasing a block is
getting added so this demonstrates the
usage of truffle and ganache in order to
build your decentralized app wow
blockchain is amazing thanks for
explaining these things to me I'm glad I
could help you and with that we have
come to the end of this video on
blockchain in-depth tutorial I hope you
found this video informative and
interesting
please feel free to ask any questions
you have concerning the topics covered
in this video in the comments box below
our expert will assist you in addressing
your problems thank you for watching
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here